I'll protect your pets you're my man oh
god he got me Shannon Shannon we need it
bad that's gotta stop ah ah no chatter
shut it Kevin where are you baby
Shannon baby girl ah ah [ __ ] it was all
a dream
damn it the game got updated so
everything resets itself so [ __ ] I have
to replay everything it's okay I'll
enjoy my last martini one more time
where it is
chase mates hey we are aa wonderful
mornin I got my paddle paddle over there
super speed damn I am faster only okay
whoa okay so the game got updated there
supposed to be a bunch of new cool stuff
there's supposed to be whales I think he
now has that's pretty cool I hope we can
kill one of them I love whales
especially bad ones
all right let's explore our new island
what do we got we got a Jennifer hey
Berta love you hey doctor grab a the one
mate I put I wasn't trying to hide from
you or anything because I love you
thanks dr. kramm
I love you too you've been such an
inspiration to me on throughout the
years all right whatever pace I'm just
gonna go over here but now mr. Grabner
I'm fine poets Jesus Christ I'll think
I'll mr. Crabb I don't know what I would
do it's dr. kramm see you later duck
bread all right let's go on the boat huh
there it is ah yeah what do we got
ah heavy ah propeller Oh Oh a flashlight
awesome now how the [ __ ] am I can I get
out of here oh that's nice an arm that's
nice I'm stuck now aren't I
great that's this [ __ ] great what am
I doing with this arm no you're not a
Nazi Jesus Christ what's going on over
there
let's take our boat and fly there our
goal is to fly to i'ma make it my Mecca
trees ah we are gonna build a motorboat
in this episode what are we gonna do
Naxos aw hey tree tree stop dancing so
far so amazing I would say so what do we
need for our motorboat we have a
propeller we have a bucket let's try it
no that that's not it that's not how a
motor works all right make a tree let's
go make a tree under the sea with make a
tree we fly forever because I love
Heather
now wait but don't tell my dear all
right I'm just kidding the trees Heather
okay um all right cut that out uh all
right Gavin your name is Heather now how
about that me and Heather explos oh god
okay I had Heather protect me okay what
is that what is dead ever ever ever do
is ever gather open protect me Heather
oh god it's a shake what the [ __ ] are
you doing Heather Heather I know your
scam scared poets
I'm scared shut up Heather aah aah what
was that
I know you're scared but damn
it's just it's this Chenin hey Shannon
how you doing hey buds see it's fine
am I am i dying oh why am i ah I got it
bowl no wait oh [ __ ] I got this I got
pimples all over me
ah what do I got what disease is this I
knew I shouldn't have slept with that
shark Shannon that son of a [ __ ] she's
she said she was fine she said she
didn't want to use a condom get him we
may be dying from pimples uh duct tape
what the [ __ ] am I gonna put up all
right we got the duct tape I'm guessing
we need it for the motor but I may be
dying but that's yeah I'm really dying
okay come past sweet that's awesome
that's really helpful
sweet wouldn't love my propeller though
well there's you Heather you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I waited for you put shut up Oh
Heather no Heather now going without me
puts look oh god oh god oh god I gotta
gotta gotta gotta gotta get that boom
boom boom
Betsy miss gasps aah aah aah
it's body way Oh what the binoculars
[ __ ] Heather
yeah oh you will regret the day that you
challenge the kaga versa how is it
raining in the water oh this is this is
some duel of the fates huh where is it
ah [ __ ] me ah I got it yeah
Heather I'll come back for you oh god
they can smell my blood hey buddy are
you doing Rich's [ __ ] you challenged me
you challenged me
yeah come at me bro look you're coming
with me
hi pods hiya Devin ah man I missed you
nearly kill me Shannon oh man I'm so
sorry bright like I had no idea Jesus
Christ Shannon fly me to safety I'm glad
I didn't fix his bug the bug I'm a
chakra shut up shut shut shut oh god
you're so annoying
you [ __ ] [ __ ] Shannon you have any
idea how much problems you cost me
answer me god damn it don't even look at
me my health is so bad
relax Brad you're gonna be fine breath
hey why don't you save me
cuddle up against the fire in now I'll
tell you a bedtime story
Oh sexy sir sexy
goddammit Shannon it's not like that
anymore it's not like that I lost
Heather watch who's Heather I'll [ __ ]
kappa baptise is quite an accomplice of
tracting the chicks
protect me Shannon and it's my
girlfriend mmm-hmm
stay away from my man girl oh yeah you
don't touch him he's mine
thanks Channing I don't think that's
gonna do it well I'm upset about it
alright just keep swimming we'll be fine
why don't you just take me here pits
shut up okay there we go
take some speed there we go fly on the
wings of Shannon flashin and flew
reaching the stairs of Beth where the
[ __ ] are we make me fly you [ __ ] I know
you can do it
okay well that's okay I don't know
what's going on this is what happens
when you make love to a shark
alright then alright alright that's cool
and we're down here Shannon what did you
do
Shannon but ah Bogart my anus we're fine
I'm fine I'm fine
sorry just shark things hashtag
shark-related no no no ed crash Steven
oh that's it's great I'm happy about
that cuz I didn't save well this has
been a productive day I hope you enjoyed
it it's not like fun if you want more
stranded deep and I will spend an hour
replaying everything I just did but
anyway I hope you enjoyed watching as
always stay awesome brush
you